[Music]  president obama's re-election campaign  is having trouble settling on a new  slogan you know they haven't found  anything as effective as 2008's change  you can believe in  now you can tell from recent speeches  that the president's been trying out new  slogans and he's had mixed results  take a look  the american people understand is  required to win the future i laid out a  blueprint  for an economy that is built to last  philosophy is simple we are better off  when everybody is left to fend for  themselves i want to be clear this plan  like the other actions we've taken will  not help the neighbors down the street  maybe i wasn't born in this country but  i'll sign  a debt that has grown over the last  decade  primarily as a result of two wars  two massive tax cuts and an  unprecedented financial crisis  will have to be paid  [Applause]  i can down  i'm gonna have trouble getting that on a  bumper stick yeah